♪♪♪♪
-Now we're gonna need anothe
player to fill out the table
We have the man for the job.
Please welcome Colin's co-star
from "True Detective,"
Vince Vaughn,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now we're talking.
Now we're talking, baby.
Here we go.
Now we're talking right here
Yes, indeed! Yes!
-Thank you.
-Here we go. Now...
Thank you for joining us.
In front of each of us
are two envelopes --
or on-velopes --
containing confessions.
Some of the envelopes,
or on-velopes,
is something that actually
happened to us in real life.
And the second envelope
is a lie.
-He's showing off
with his wordplay, by the way.
-So once you read
your confession,
the other two players
have 60 seconds
to interrogate you.
And then they each have to guess
whether you have been lyin
or telling the truth.
We'll take one turn each.
Colin, you'll go first.
Vince, which envelope
should he choose?
Number one or number two?
What do you think?
-Number two.
-Yeah.
-You sure?
-Oh, yeah.
-Positive, now?
-I'm watching everything, Colin.
-Yeah.
-He's twitching.
He's twitching.
-"When I was --"
-Lie.
-"When I was a late teen,
I got brought in
for questioning as a suspect
in an attempted murder."
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Did you do it?
-How long ago was it?
I want to see if the statute
of limitations is...
-What was the case?
-So it's not a yes and no?
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
The case was, uh, a guy...
a guy in a nightclub was -
-What was the name
of the nightclub?
-I don't know.
-Give me the name!
-It was someplace -- For God's
sake! I was some place in --
It was a long time ago,
and I was drunk.
-Yeah.
It was a long time ago.
-Do you take a shower
or do you use a tub?
What was the guy's name?!
-Howard.
-What was his name?!
-Calm down now.
Let him talk.
-I saw photo fit of the gu
that actually did the crime,
and it looked remarkably
like me,
and for a second, because I ha
had a blackout that night,
I wondered, "Could I have done
such a thing?"
-Hmm.
What did the person look like?
What was their hair --
-Had bushy eyebrows,
a mole on his face,
spoke even in two dimensions
with an Irish accent.
-Did they catch the killer
-No.
-We're out of time.
-I'm a little nervous
to push too hard
'cause we might have a guy
who got away with murder.
Well, I want to play a fun game,
but...
-[ Laughs ]
This is like "The Jinx."
This is like the other HBO show,
"The Jinx."
-He could hit the head in here
and say, "I killed him."
-Stop.
I'm gonna start belching.
-[ Laughs ] Okay. All right.
What do you think?
-Well, I don't know.
-No. Of course not. No.
I didn't do -- What I did was...
No.
-That's a good -- All right.
That's a great impression.
-I got a feeling that this
really happened to him,
and I'm afraid.
-Yeah, me too.
-I'm a little afraid
of Colin Farrell.
-I'd be afraid if, you know,
if that happened to me, too.
-What do you think?
-I'm afraid, too.
I actually think
that he's a suspect. Yeah.
I think it's true.
True story.
-And we're gonna move past it,
but I think you were.
-It was true?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whatever you want.
Whatever you want, Colin.
-I'm still here.
-Can we get Colin
a limousine ride home?
-I'm still here, baby.
-That had to be
an uncomfortable moment.
-Very. Yeah.
And was I supposed to brin
my mother to the airport.
I was in Sydney, Australia
and I was I was pulled in
by the cops,
and they showed me a photo fit
of a pencil sketch of the gu
that had attempted to murder
this other gentleman,
had beat him up and left him
in his own apartment
and set the apartment on fir
and split,
thereby leaving the guy to bur
to death, and it was me.
They said, "What do you thin
about that picture?"
And I went,
"I think I'm in trouble."
Yeah. It was terrifying.
I was there for about six hours,
and then, thankfully,
a friend of mine had kept
a journal.
And that particular night
and that particular time,
we were at a party the other
side of town doing ecstasy
So it was...
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Can we get Elmo out of here
Can we get Elmo
out of the building?
Just get him out
of the building.
-What's Elmo cooking?
Elmo -- Some appetizers?
Anything.
-Some dip? Some crudités?
-Some meth?
-Elmo does a mean crudités
-Here we go. This is my turn
Which envelope should I open
-Uh, number one, Jimmy Fallon.
-Here we go. Number one.
-I'm watching you, Fallon.
-Yeah. Here we go.
-I'll be good cop, then.
-Uh...
-How are you?
[ Laughter ]
-Great. Thanks for asking.
-Don't be nervous.
This will be over really,
really quick.
-This seems really fun.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're just gonna have
a quick chat.
-I-I got my I got my head stuc
in a fence
and my grandma used mayonnaise
to squeeze me out of it.
[ Laughter ]
-What was your grandma's name?
-My grandma's name was Gloria.
-Mother or father's mom?
-My mother's mom.
-How old were you?
-I was probably...10.
-So your head was about
this big.
-Yeah. Yeah.
About that big.
-And the families get along?
-Yeah, fam--
-Some turmoil?
-No turmoil.
-What are you hiding, Fallon
[ Laughter ]
-No turmoil. Yeah.
No -- No turmoil at all.
-What brand was the mayo?
What brand was the mayo?
What?
[ Laughter, applause ]
-I'm sorry.
-Why did you put your head in it
in the first place?
-Uh, a curious child.
-Curious child?
-Yeah. I want to see if I coul
fit it through there, probably
And it wasn't, like,
a chain-link fence.
It was probably, like, two -
two, uh...
-Did that happen much
when you were a child?
You wanted to see how you coul
fit it through there?
-Were you always fitting thing
with stuff that would help i
fit in different things?
Or just the head with the mayo
in the fence?
-Was there any other time
your grandma used mayonnaise
to extract your thing from -
your head from something
it was trapped in?
-Were you attracted
to your grandma?
-No, I was not -- No.
-Jimmy, were you attracted
to your grandma?
-The questioning is now over
Yeah. All right.
The questioning is over.
-I think this is going great
[ Laughter ]
-Thoughts.
-I'm tuning in Sunday nigh
to watch you.
-Thank you.
And you as well, sir.
-I wasn't sure until this show
-What are your thoughts on this?
-I mean, I think that it was -
it's untrue but beautiful.
And I hope I'm wrong.
I hope I'm wrong.
-You've got a strong feeling
I'm gonna ride your thoughts
on this.
-It actually is true.
-Ah!
Beautiful.
-It was an outdoor thing.
It was a gate. It was outdoors
And it was a summer day.
It was really hot.
And I was crying, and my ear
were, like, stuck on the fence
And I was like this
in the fence.
And my grandma goes,
"I think I know."
And she rubbed mayonnaise
on my hair and all over my hea
to squeeze me out of it.
And I think that's probably wh
I don't like mayonnaise.
-How long were you stuck
in the fence?
-Probably like an hour
or something.
-So two things I can take
with me for parenting tonight.
That and you're not
completely useless.
You could be used
as a bad example.
-That's a good one, right?
Yeah. That's good.
All right. Vince Vaughn.
Now it is your turn.
Why don't you open up
envelope number one?
-I would love to.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm watching everything.
-"I once --"
-Lie!
-Yeah.
-I don't believe it either
-"I once defiantly commanded
the stage
in the title role of Oscar
Hammerstein's "The King and I.
Questions, please.
-Oh, wow.
-How long ago was this?
Was this early in your career?
-Yes.
-Did you wear a bald cap?
-I did.
-Is there any reviews
that exist?
-I don't know that
you could find those online.
-What percentage
of Rotten Tomatoes thought
you were commanding the stage?
-Rotten Tomatoes was not aroun
at this time.
-Lie! He's right. He's right
-He is right about that.
What was the song you sang
-There was lots of songs.
-Yeah.
Give me one of them.
-"Getting to Know You,"
getting to know all about you.
-It was one of them.
-Yeah, that's definitely one
[ Laughter ]
-It's just two lines
from the same song.
-What else?
-You asked me
for one of the songs I sang.
I was trying --
-It was a long time ago.
-That's interesting,
'cause we have a band here
They could probably play
that type of song.
-Oh, I'd love to hear it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Getting to know... ♪♪
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Introduction plays ]
-Take it away, baby.
-I have to do it
like Yul Brynner,
like I did in the play.
♪♪ Getting to know you ♪♪
♪♪ Getting to know
all about you ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Et cetera, et cetera.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Repeat, repeat.
-Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
All right. Very good.
Nice job.
-Long 60 seconds,
but let's keep doing it.
-No. That's good.
Colin, what do you think?
Truth or lie?
-I think it's a lie.
-I think it's the truth.
I think that you played
the king.
You were in "The King and I,
and you sang.
You sang very well.
-I think you're right.
I think that's the truth.
-He sang very well. Yeah.
You say, both, truth.
-I was the king
in "The King and I."
-That's right! I knew it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you all very much.
-We're about to play
a very suspenseful new game.
It is called True Confessions.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll need two more players
to fill out this table.
The first one is a multipl
Emmy Award winner
and New York Times
best-selling author.
She was also my partner
on Weekend Update
at "Saturday Night Live."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello to Tina Fey,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Tina,
we'll need one more player
-Yes.
-And you brought the best on
possible with you tonight.
She is a Golden Globe Awar
winner.
She's also
a best-selling author.
She was also your partner
on Weekend Update.
-[ Chuckles ]
-And on December 18th
of this year,
you guys are starring together
in a big, hilarious new movi
called "Sisters."
Here's our pal Amy Poehler
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Coming in hot!
Come on. This is the best.
-All right. Oh.
-Okay, everybody.
Here's how the game works.
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
In one of the envelopes
is something that actually
happened to us in real life.
And in the second envelope
is a lie.
-Right.
-Okay?
Once you've read
your confession,
the other two people have
60 seconds to interrogate you.
And they have to guess
whether or not you've been lying
or telling the truth.
We'll take one turn each.
Tina, you'll go first.
Amy, which envelope
should Tina open?
-One or two.
-Hmm. Could be either one.
-[ Clears throat ]
Number one, please.
-Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-By the way,
great to see you both.
-Yeah. It is great to see you.
-It's very nice to meet you.
[ Laughter ]
"I was once mistaken
for a prostitute in Monaco."
[ Laughter ]
-In Monaco?
-In Monaco.
The small country.
[ Laughter ]
-What year was this?
-Uh, 1992.
-How did you get to Monaco
-I was on a trip with my cousi
visiting Europe.
-Just you and your cousin
in '92?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-You ever been to Europe
before then?
-Yes.
-And what were you wearing
-I can tell you.
I was wearing a brown-and-whit
polka-dot jumpsuit
that I had bought at --
-Were you in an ABBA tribute
band?
-I bought at Express.
-A brown-and-white polka dot
-Brown-and-white --
It looked fantastic.
-Fantastic enough to be confused
as a prostitute?
-I don't see you in Monaco
either.
I don't see you there.
What were some sights that you
saw in Monaco?
-Yeah. What do you see so much
you big seer?
-Okay.
I went to a casino there because
my cousin's from New Jerse
and we thought
it was gonna be fun
like an Atlantic City casino
But it was like a creepy
James Bond casino
and there was only like
40 people in the whole place
-And what games
were they playing?
-Baccarat.
[ Laughter ]
-Burt Baccarat?
-All right.
Burt Baccarat.
Uh, okay.
-Let me ask you this.
Were you ever a prostitute
in Monaco?
-No. Wait. We're out of time
We're out of time now.
Here we go.
-Whoo!
-Now, Amy, we have to decide
Amy, what did you think?
Truth or lie?
-Well, you know, it's very hard,
'cause I feel like I know
almost everything about Tina
but I don't know her early years
as well.
But I'm gonna say
that was a lie.
-[ Laughs ]
-I also know a little bit
about you.
I don't -- I don't --
I could see you going to Express
and getting a jumpsuit.
[ Laughter ]
I can really see that.
I don't see you going
to Monaco either
and getting mistaken
for a prostitute.
Mm.
Well, do I tell you now?
-Yes.
-It is true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-Yes. Yes.
-And then what happened?
How did...
-We went to the casino.
Again, we thought it was gonna
be like bands playing
or whatever,
and it was just ice cold,
just weird Europeans
just quietly gambling.
We were the youngest peopl
there.
And my cousin is really pretty
She's blond and really tall.
And I was just, like, with her
like...
-You were doing that?
[ Laughter ]
-And we realized, like,
"Oh, this is not our scene."
And then this sort of, like,
older gentleman came over
and was like, "I would lov
to buy the two of you dinner
in this restaurant here."
And it was like
a weird restaurant in the back
And my cousin was like, "Yeah!
And I was like, "No.
I don't think this is
a good idea."
And it just sort of became clear
that the only possible
explanation for why we would
have been in there
is that we were prostitutes.
-And that is where Tina me
her husband.
-Yes.
-It's a great story.
It's a fantastic story.
It's beautiful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right. It's my turn.
Which envelope should I open
Tina?
-Um, I'm gonna say number tw
'cause poop.
[ Laughter ]
That's not funny.
-Come on. That's funny.
Get out of here. Oh!
-Hey, kids. That's funny.
-All right.
-Oh! I spilled the coffee.
-No. It's all right. Don't..
-Shoot.
Our props.
-Poop. Poop.
Okay.
-Our props! Our props!
Our cigarettes!
[ Laughter ]
-No one believes that they'r
really smoking anyway.
Here we go.
"In college, my friend and I
were robbed by a drug dealer
with a sawed-off shotgun."
[ Laughter ]
-First of all,
what college did you go to
[ Laughter ]
-Clown College.
Uh, I went to the College
of St. Rose in Albany, New York.
-What was your friend's name
Uh, Sean.
-That's not true.
You only have one friend.
His name is Gerard.
[ Laughter ]
-It wasn't Gerard.
-Yeah. That's suspicious.
-All right.
-This guy's name was Sean.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
-And, um --
How did you know
he was a drug dealer?
-Uh, I didn't.
I didn't know
he was a drug dealer.
I was actually going
to his house
'cause he was gonna give m
a ride to the mall.
-Uh-huh.
-So I was just waiting in hi
living room for him to come out.
He had some business
to take care of.
-And how had you met
this person?
-He's a friend of another friend
that I went to college with.
-Hey, you got kids.
[ Laughter ]
-You're the tough cop?
Yeah. Yes, I got kids.
-You ever think about them
when you go to buy drugs?
[ Laughter ]
-It wasn't --
I wasn't buying drugs.
-Well, it sounds like you were
-I was not.
-These cigarettes
are really smoky.
-I spilled the coffee
everywhere.
Okay.
-I think it's...a lie.
-I think it's true
and you did a bad job of telling
the story on purpose.
-Ah!
I still think it's a lie.
-Okay, I'm gonna say true
but you pretended
like it was fake.
And you're gonna say?
-I'll say fake just so we have
an option.
-Okay.
-Thank you.
It is the truth.
-Ah!
-It happened to me in -- Yeah.
[ Applause ]
It was a weird thing.
I didn't know my friend
was a drug dealer.
I went over 'cause he was gonn
give me a ride to the mall
And I go and I was waiting
for this ride.
He goes, "I just got to talk
to my friend.
I'll be out in two seconds."
I go, "Cool."
Then dude came out
with a duffel bag.
They got in a fight, and h
came in with a duffel bag,
pulled out a shotgun,
pointed at me,
and told me to get
on the ground.
And I was like,
"What's going on?"
-"In 25 years,
I'm gonna be very important!
-"What is going on?"
And then he left and took off.
I go to my friend,
"What was that all about?
He goes, "Sorry, dude.
It was a drug dealer,"
or something like that.
He goes, "I don't want to
get into it now."
I go, "Oh my God. All right.
I'm gonna go home.
I mean, we're not gonna go
to the mall?"
He goes, "No, we can't,
because that guy stole my car.
So we ended up
not going to the mall either
That was a real bummer.
-Mall bummer.
All right.
Here we go.
Amy, you are up.
-[ Clears throat ]
-You pick.
-Oh, yeah. Okay.
I'll pick.
Uh, I'm gonna say number one
'cause you guys are number one
-Thanks, dude.
-Nice.
-So are you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
"I once helped Yoko Ono
cross the street."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. All right, all right.
Wait a second.
-Aw.
I find that extremely plausible.
-Okay.
-I don't know if she needs hel
crossing the street.
That's the only reason why..
-That's true.
She's fit.
-She's perfectly fine.
-What street was it?
-I'd love to hear a question
-What street?
[ Laughter ]
-It was 66th.
Like, it was around
the Phillips Club area.
-Phillips Club.
I don't know what that means
It was -- I don't know.
Upper West Side?
-What do you do in those clubs
-You look for Phillips.
[ Laughter ]
-She knows the Upper West Side
She lives over there, right?
She owns a part of Central Park.
-Yoko does.
She knows her way around.
-You, though.
What was Yoko wearing?
-She was wearing a black -
like, a jacket
and a jaunty black hat
and, like, tiny black jeans.
-Was she wearing a polka-dot
jumpsuit from Express?
Oh, really?
Did you know Yoko Ono?
What'd you say to her?
-I didn't know it was her.
But she was in the middle
of the street,
and she was kind of, like,
what I thought was disoriented
And I was like, "Ma'am,
are you okay?"
And then I realized
it was Yoko Ono.
And so I just said, like -
I-I kind of just, like, led he
to the other side of the street.
-Really?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And what did she say to you?
-She was standing
in the middle of the street,
and maybe it was an art project,
but I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-When was this?
-This was like three years ago
All right. Three years ago
Okay. All right.
We're out of time.
This is a toughie, man.
-It's funny, because I feel like
it could be a lie.
It could be the opposite
what you did.
It could be a lie
that she's sold very, very well.
-Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
But I think that you're
a very nice person.
You would help someone
cross the street.
But also, as a fan of art,
I think you would just let
the piece play out.
So...
-That means a lot to me.
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
-Thank you.
I am such a fan of art. Oh
-Fan of art. Oh.
-I think of you all the time
at the galleries.
At the Phillips Club.
You're always at the
Phillips Club, looking at art.
[ Laughter ]
"Is Art here?"
"No, just Phillips only."
I'm gonna say --
I'm gonna say that is a lie.
-I'm gonna agree.
I think it's a lie.
-Yeah. That's a bald-faced lie
-Well, congratulations.
It's a lie.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You tried to fake me out
with the art thing!